hey everyone and welcome back to the
channel sorry I haven't posted in a
little bit been doing some traveling
seeing some family uh good news is I am
going to post a little bit more in the
next coming weeks and also I have
another collaboration coming up which is
great because it means I'm yet again
increasing my chances of accidentally
doxing myself and getting fired at work
so if that happens I'll be posting
plenty more anyways let's talk about
time series databases
so what exactly is a Time series
database well if you guess that it helps
you handle graph data you are a bozo and
incorrect it helps you handle time
series data which is really just a fancy
way of saying any piece of data that you
mainly care about the time series range
that it's a part of basically any type
of graph or line plot or anything like
that and so that could be logs it could
be metrics it could be sensor readings
it could be any piece of data where the
main access pattern that we want to use
is accessing it by some sort of time
range and so there are many different
types of Time series databases this
video is most going to be inspired by
time scale DB but there's also influx DB
and Apache Druid so feel free to look
into those as well
so how is it that time series databases
are going to allow us to optimize reads
writes and actually as well deletes
let's start talking about them so one
way that it does things is pretty simple
we've spoken about this a lot on this
channel which is using column oriented
storage so because time series databases
will typically tend to include many
different Columns of data but typically
we only care about one or two at a time
using column oriented storage ensures
that we are only fetching The Columns
that we care about and ensures that
we're getting better data locality and
because we're only say fetching one
column at a time instead of fetching an
entire row at a time we can do some
handy things with compression and just
improving our caching in general to make
sure that our cache only contains the
data that we want so like I said better
dislocality can cash more less data to
fetch column oriented storage obviously
going to help a lot in any type of
analytical workflow and time series
databases are often going to be using
that
so what else can we do to continue to
optimize our reads
okay so this is something that is kind
of unique to the time series database
and it is also going to help us a lot
with both our rights and our delete and
that is using something known as a hyper
table and so this is our hyper table
right here you can see we've got this
three by three grid and each of these
pieces of the grid I will call a chunk
table
so if you think about it for something
like a Time series database the reason
that we want to be using something like
this is because we're effectively
parameterizing our data by two main
things one is where it's coming from so
let's imagine we have some sensors you
know you've got Sensor One sensor two
and sensor three and another typical
thing that we would do is the actual
range of time that that data belongs in
so we've got one o'clock to two o'clock
two o'clock to three o'clock three
o'clock to four o'clock
so typically if we were to be using a
traditional database what you would do
is you would just have a single index
over all of that data right and that's
great it helps a lot uh and you can even
be pretty smart about that index where
you you know first sort based on sensor
and then you sort based on the timestamp
however
actually using a bunch of little chunk
tables like this are really useful
because it means that we can be very
precise with the amount of data that
we're caching right so let's say I just
took this guy right here you know I only
care about sensor 3 from one o'clock to
two o'clock and I know that in advance
that's where all my queries are going I
can just place this entire thing in our
cache whereas for example you know if
are we were just using a normal database
perhaps I would do a couple of reads
that went in this range right here and
then we would naively cache this whole
thing when we really just want this area
in our cache so the chunk table is going
to help us a little bit more in writes
and deletes and we'll talk about that in
a second but this is how it helps us
with reads
so how does our chunk table help us with
optimizing rights well for starters
basically like I mentioned every single
chunk table is going to be maintaining
its own index so like for a given sensor
right here sensor one we've got our
chunk that is corresponding to it same
thing with sensor 2. and the really nice
thing about splitting these tables up
this way is that we can actually do
something like keep this chunk local to
the same node that the sensor is on so
that way we don't incur any extra
Network latency had we partitioned our
system in a different manner where say
you could have multiple sensors to a
chunk then you might have to write a
bunch of data over the network but by
keeping all of these chunks local we can
make ingestions or rights really really
fast additionally if we want to make
writes faster what something like time
scale DB will use is use a typical LSM
tree plus SS table architecture which is
fast because rights first go to memory
go to memory and then eventually they'll
be written to disk and compacted and do
all that fun stuff which we've spoken
about extensively on this channel so
again we are getting the best data
locality here because our chunk tables
are actually on the nodes where we're
writing from they don't necessarily have
to be but this is a great optimization
if you care about fast write speeds
and then the last aspect of this is
actually going to be delete so the
interesting thing or interesting
compromise perhaps about using SS tables
and LSM trees is that they're basically
when you're deleting an item it is just
as expensive as a right so the delete
would first go into here right into your
table and eventually it is going to be
put into an SS table and so you can see
for the Key C over here we write that we
delete it and then in an older version
of the SS table we have the old value of
the key and then after we compact these
two files what we would have is that a
is 10 because we're using the new value
of a we have that b is eight we have
that c is deleted or actually when you
compact those we probably wouldn't even
have C in this file and then you would
have that f is 15. so the point is
whenever you delete a key it's actually
just as expensive as doing a right and
in Time series databases a typical use
case is to drop data once it gets too
old and so we don't want to have to drop
a ton of data and effectively just right
over it that's super expensive and there
are a lot better ways of doing this so
again this is where having chunk tables
is going to help us a lot so instead you
know let's imagine this is like our one
o'clock range this is our two o'clock
range and this is sensor A
and this is sensor b
this guy right here
is just a bunch of files on disk
and so instead of doing all these rights
to memory and letting them propagate to
disk we can pretty much just say well we
can overwrite this data now we don't
care about it it's free it's overridden
we just drop the table which is a lot
less expensive than having to do an
equal amount of rights to the amount of
data on that disk so again chunk table
is super useful in this regard
deleting significant portions of data is
a pretty unique taste to time series
databases and so it is actually
something that we want to be able to
optimize or else that would be a super
expensive operation
so what's our conclusion well pretty
simple basically time series databases
will come up from time to time in
interview questions and also hopefully
in your career because whenever you have
something like metrics or logs and you
want to be able to store and access them
efficiently being able to leverage a
Time series database for its interesting
properties that make both reading
writing and deleting faster is going to
help us a lot of course when it comes to
something like an interview it's not
enough to just say hey we have time
series data let's use a Time series
database you also need to know how they
work under the hood or else the
interviewer is going to call you out and
you're going to look like a bozo anyways
guys hope you have a great weekend I
will see you in the next video and I'm
looking forward to it